to all who come to this happy place
welcome memories
[Music]
okay based off of looks I just want to
point out the amazing Disney bound here
I think I just want to go ahead and
start out by asking you to come right up
here yeah it's valid visually I've just
never seen so many pins before
yeah I think we should move up further
you're more like bubbly outgoings I
think yeah like maybe you look like
you're on your honeymoon right right
here yeah I am just gonna go down here I
feel like because I'm just wearing all
black I'm just in a T-shirt and a hat
though and you have the bracelet too oh
yeah okay I guess I'll stay I guess
perhaps I should move to the end since
I'm in the least Disney guard but it's a
spirit jersey it's a classic yeah I feel
like you have a lot of knowledge I'm
looking at you I think you have a lot
more knowledge that you're putting on
Disney adult is more of a personality
thing I think like I don't visually I
don't know I feel like there's different
types of Disney adults and there's some
who like have the total aesthetic and
the collections and then there's those
who have just the magic and the
personality and that's so you I still
feel like I should move down like one or
two
sure yeah yeah we'll switch
are you sure
all right we're locking it in yeah yeah
yeah getting locked in they looked at me
saw my opinions and my tattoos and they
threw me at the top I'm like whoa that
was surprising most of my life people
looked at me and just see a guy with
tattoos and with a beard and everything
you wouldn't think oh this guy's listens
to princess music on the way to work
every day or works out to Once Upon a
Time in the gym or anything like that
hey good humans Jason here when I'm
feeling blue I always feel better after
watching a classic Disney film Lion King
anyone uh Comfort movies and therapy do
wonders for my mental health so I want
to give a quick shout out to betterhelp
for sponsoring this portion of today's
video better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues to get started all you have to do
is answer a few questions about your
needs and preferences in therapy that
way better help can match you with the
right therapist from their Network then
you can talk to your therapist however
you feel comfortable whether it's via
text chat phone or video call you can
message your therapist at any time and
schedule live sessions when it's
convenient for you if your therapist
isn't the right fit for any reason you
can switch to a new therapist at no
additional charge with better help you
get the same professionalism and quality
you expect from in-office therapy but
with a therapist who's custom pick for
you more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price I personally have
used betterhelp and I love it check out
the link in the description below or
scan this QR code to get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com Jubilee
media that's better
help.com Jubilee media thank you again
to better help for sponsoring this
episode and let's get back to the video
guys this is my very first pair of ears
in 1995. my mother kept this my nickname
is Tiger my entire family calls me that
they don't call me Michael they call me
tiger and then of course the Loudoun
proud obviously the Disneyland
Championship so I literally carry this
every time I go you made that I designed
it I even had a young boy he followed me
for about 30 minutes because he was
terrified to go up to me like dude take
it dude just like Mom on the chair so
the the metal detectors don't go off
there was always one security guard
named Robert he knows me like yeah oh
the chat
appreciate you this is Pluto from Tokyo
Pluto is my absolute favorite cases
and this is my Club 33 pin
um wow and I got to go one time and so I
splurged on a pit I grew up going to
Tokyo Disney these are uh first year
tickets from 1983. it's not mine I was
not born in 1983. all right so mine are
my Vera Wang ears
yes yes it's very limited because of my
Disney content creator path I was able
to purchase these and it just really
means a lot because we didn't have a lot
of money growing up and we weren't able
to afford Disney trips so me being able
to purchase this pair of ears was like a
really really big deal so the first one
I have is my annual pass from 2008.
there's a little photo of me as like a
little baby
on it and then the second thing um my
biggest connection with Disney is
definitely my relationship with my mom
we always spent like Mother's Day there
and all that stuff this is just one of
the three or four I have of all the
charms that she bought me every single
time we went together okay so this
little guy right here um he's supposedly
from Japan 1960s roughly um he also
squeaks for some reason
so like these are supposed to be his
legs but yeah when you spread it like
that I don't know
these are his feet I guess so I brought
uh my favorite movie The Little Mermaid
this is the first VHS tape that my mom
got me I used to watch it like on repeat
like every every single day for a couple
hours and you guys want to rearrange
yourselves based off of those
possessions
you're the champ this thing is throwing
me off I'm so sorry the only way you can
search this up is through reverse Google
image search like that's how okay
I still think we should switch really
yeah a thousand percent yeah
yeah
I think so yeah okay we good here
[Music]
favorite Disney park or experience you
guys have been to Dapper Day I love it's
everyday so much fun going and grad
night just in the park with thousands of
kids here look my school's bad from
Disneyland I had to go to Six Flags over
there
so the Park's opening you're there like
what are the first five rides you go to
if you're going to if you're going to
Disneyland if it's just me and my wife
then we're here uh Space Mountain star
towards Indiana Jones Galaxy's Edge come
back to Matterhorn it was the whole plan
hot hot take but I don't really do rope
drop because it's just too many people
too crazy you know that scene in Lion
King the one where we don't the one that
we don't know the wildebeest they're
just yet yes
oh no how much do you guys spend on a
typical day at a Disney park well I'm a
college student so like at maximum 30
bucks
I have
um a shopping problem yes I'm in debt
but that's okay I'm in Disney debt and
that's Happy debt so I'm debating
switching usage yeah I splurge on the
food and all right let's switch let's
switch
[Laughter]
do you guys want to get into what Disney
means to you guys it started from when I
was a kid watching the movies because we
couldn't afford to go to the parks as
much so um I would watch a lot of Disney
movies and a Little Mermaid was my first
introduction to Disney the pure joy of
everybody lingo literally anywhere in
the world and you say Disney or Mickey
Mouse and someone knows what you're
talking about exactly there really is
something there for everyone at the park
for me kind of all my Social Circles
kind of relate to Disney like all my
friends we have magic key passes and
everything I mean it's called the
happiest place on Earth it's like it's a
source of Happiness it's like I don't
have to think about like student loan
debt or I can just like forget about
everything and then just like go back to
like happy nostalgic times when I've
been there with my friends or like
family members who might not be here
anymore
it's definitely
we used to go with my great grandma
especially when they had a cookie
decorating at the park so we'd go during
Christmas time and then we'd go with my
dad
a lot too and
but it's nice to like to go there and
then like sort of like oh hey this is
what this is uh this was his favorite
ride this was uh this was my great
grandmother's favorite food and stuff
like that and like kind of like
relive that and then just kind of
imagine how they would think like how
the park has changed since then
you will see me every single time crying
at Fantasmic every fireworks show and
like the connection like I said with my
mom we have like little tattoos matching
tattoos of the neverland stars together
I grew up in Japan and Disney is like
the first exposure to Western movies for
Asian kids I would say so you know every
Japanese kid knows about Disney movies
and I also I don't know if we can get
into this but I feel like in defense of
Disney adults a lot of hobbies are
rooted in childhood people collect comic
books and like build model railroads I
don't know why Disney adults get a bad
rep for enjoying Nostalgia and trying to
go back to a simpler time in childhood I
really don't understand how someone
crying when they see Cinderella's castle
how that's hurting anybody but I guess
it's cringe because we're older and
people think Disney's for kids people
have to do what makes them happy and I
think that's the problem with Society
now is we're so trained to do what
people think we should do and I just
think it's just important to stay true
to yourself there's such a stigma
there's such a stigma they're just like
crapping on everybody else's happiness
it's just like let people be happy for
what they like yeah like we're not
hurting anyone yeah for the sigma
honestly it's people that think we don't
take things seriously we still want to
be a kid we want to goof around which is
to be honest kind of true but at a time
once it's time to go for real in the
real life and work pay bills do what we
got to do we'll flip that switch real
quick then again when it's time to fund
well that's what should be fun it's fun
to be weird it's boring to be normal and
like I feel like there's always niches
and that's the beautiful thing about the
human race is that there's so many
different hobbies for everyone to enjoy
yeah it's a fandom I'm happy to be part
of a community that's very in touch with
their inner child and happy to be a big
kid no matter what there's just
something that the family Legacy
resonates in all of us that we're all
kind of part of this big family when we
go to Disneyland it's such a place of
escape to all who come to this happy
place
of the future
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I don't know this
I don't know if I belong here
has anyone worked at Disney
okay yeah yeah I should that's right can
you guys talk a little bit about some of
you have brought up like the money
aspect of Disney
it's sad but Disney is kind of the
wealthy people's vacation now and it's
not very accessible to people there is
such an immense privilege I think all of
us have to be able to just to go to the
park once let alone multiple times I
mean I have a relative who waited like
70 years of her life just to be able to
go to Disney that was like her one dream
and she finally got to go and it was the
most special thing I hope people don't
take it for granted you know what I mean
absolutely yeah it just used to be well
growing up my my dad never told me this
but he would literally go broke and
we're double shifts for us to go to
Disneyland and I didn't know I was a kid
I was like oh yeah he's my inspiration
to work two jobs to take my girls to
Disneyland let them have the experience
I did my oldest daughter is named Aurora
after sleeping beauty and my youngest is
named Ariel after Little Mermaid and
those are the love of my life absolutely
adore them and every time we go to
Disneyland my oldest dad that's my
castle absolutely princess that is your
Castle or if we go to California
Adventures you see a little mermaid
daddy that's me absolutely princess that
is you 100 so I love my little girls
with all my heart I actually do have a
quick question that's okay how many
different Parks have you guys gone to
I've done all four Disney World
um the California ones and Tokyo Disney
Tokyo Disney sea for Disney World parks
Blizzard Beach caliad and Disneyland
okay
two next I've only been to California
Adventure in Disneyland also too okay
same thing in California Adventure okay
cool two all four Disney World parks DCA
Disneyland uh Typhoon Lagoon same as you
except Typhoon Lagoon yeah same thing
all Disney World Elizabeth Beach and
then of course the two in California so
said it oh yeah do the cruises
yeah
we're gonna go down here
okay yeah how do you guys feel about
this
yeah
she's thinking I feel
no this is good yes for sure sure you're
walking in yeah okay okay
[Music]
in seven we have Anna 34 times
I'm shocked yeah in sixth Jack 50 times
oh my gosh
in fifth Rossi 185 times
what is happening in fourth Grace
270 times
in third Michael
900 times oh my goodness but the champ
in second Kaylee 2 000 times
Tom Thumb bro and in first Caitlyn 5 000
times
what how do you count that literally
with the help of my parents
wow
today but yeah we would go wow
we would go like like after school when
I'm supposed to be in school right for
dinner and a few rides for lunch and a
few rides during the summer yeah and if
Disney wasn't in my life I I don't think
I'd be as positive of a person
honestly so I think um that's where a
lot of uh my happiness and positivity
comes from I didn't expect to be over
here
so you guys have been a ton too like
yeah
probably yeah about two thousand well
because I started working there when I
was 18 and it was just the people that I
worked with we became a big family I
think it doesn't matter how many times
you've been to Disneyland I think a
Disney adult is someone who's not afraid
to have magic that exists within them so
I live in Orlando I just moved there
last year did you go there for Content
creation yeah
exactly